foreign
For the First Time The agriculture
department has approved ma'am on the
left you have put so much makeup on you
look like an Instagram filter right
you're seeing it she's not ugly no one's
saying she's ugly because she does look
like a filter without a filter right
that's not that's not the best look man
look like you should have hearts and dog
ears floating above your head I mean
[__] seriously the sale of chicken
she's hot though man she is hot cell
cultivated or cultured meat oh sorry we
didn't have the restings were making fun
of her stem cell me for the first time
oh they're talking about cultured meat
it's meat that's gone to Harvard and
this is well read yes let's speak three
languages two of them fluently yes
apartment has approved the sale of
chicken made from animal cells yes cell
cultivated or cultured meat you know how
they culture it they basically give the
cells cancer yeah yeah something to grow
no there really is how they think about
it they're replicating it
yeah that's what they that's how they do
it oh you don't want cancer chicken now
oh merch is too good for cancer chicken
you already eat cancer chicken they're
just gonna make it more cancery I love
it when I [__] point something out
and I see it hit [__] Merchants but
it's true that's what they're doing
remember when we were worried about eggs
remember that like [__] 20 years ago
yeah you know who's not worried about
eggs though Chelsea Handler um
she's Barren yeah but no like I just
remember I was having like a year-long
just battle royal about eggs and it was
like that's the biggest thing we had to
worry about was like is it too much
cholesterol and are you supposed to have
a minimum amount of cholesterol and
there's a guy in an exit that runs away
from Lenny
and then there was the trans fat yeah
and it was like well maybe some of these
oils and she should be eaten too much
because it is what clogs you up yeah it
does make sense but we've gotten down to
now we're just we're eating
cancer cells yeah oh did you but I want
you to look at what is this a way of
selling us on the bugs look you could
either have the cancer meat or you could
have the bugs Guess The Crickets
um I want you to look at what it looks
like what you're eating
steel tanks that's what it looks like
when it's made using cells that come
from a living animal and that's how it
comes out you want your blob and it's
cut to mimic real meat oh and then they
paint it to look like it's like God
[__] let's eliminate harm to animals
the meat will initially be sold only at
upscale restaurants of course because
because stupid white liberal morons love
being guinea pigs for the most dystopian
[__] well yeah it's the perfect perfect
thing to eat before your site your
Titanic sub tour yeah cause it's light
on the belly you know what man
we're living in a nightmare
we're living in a [__] nightmare you
could you could eat the cancer chicken
you could eat the Locust Burger that's
all your choices now what that's it wait
we're living in a [__] nightmare man
I'm eating the cancer chicken I don't
even give a [__] jokes eat cancer
chicken joke's on you I'm eating the
AIDS tomato oh no it's tobacco actually
tobacco oh my God what a reference God I
always forget about that one Echo
stasher five dollars the reason of all
these people are such easy marks for
James O'Keefe is because they all think
they're the most interesting people in
the world but no one's interested in
them until O'Keefe's in a dress
so until 26 what do you think about
chicken made from self oh God everyone's
saying no
all is in one of those factories well
you know what it's the Overton window
it's gonna be [__] 87 next time and
then 82 and then all I got to do is get
a picture of Kim Kardashian eating one
and people are dumb bro yeah I've got a
I've got the footage they don't want you
to see of these of these cancer chickens
I just sent it all right let's check it
out
at last the ultimate party platter 50
flightless but delicious wings oh my
crisp legs of celery bowels bursting
with blue cheese oh God Sublime creature
defecate your own to-go box okay I
I know
so good but it's pretty spot-on
[Laughter]